another season of pftot
on yahoo sports peter king and mike
florio here with you to talk about the
biggest stories percolating in the
national football league and peter one
of the biggest stories of the off-season
came out of the blue in late june on a
sunday night oh my god cam newton to the
patriots plenty of questions about what
he will be for new england this year but
so far
so good he's a captain he's reportedly
the starter not that hard to win a
competition over jared stiderman brian
hoyer if you're cam newton but he's
healthy that's the key what are your
expectations for newton and patriot and
the patriots in their first year
together
well i think obviously it's it's one of
the great mysteries of this year in my
opinion of the 32 teams in football i
think the patriots with their huge
questions at linebacker they lost all
four starters and obviously without
brady
still with an absolutely below par
receiving core
um
you know i think it's i think
it's going to be more a question
of can cam newton lift this team around
him okay because we saw the patriots
last year even with all their faults
shot out of the cannon they were eight
no and then after halloween they had a
worse record than the miami dolphins
and really the offensive weaponry came
into play and really ended up hurting
them
poor separation with defensive backs and
all that so right now
i think cam the biggest question for cam
newton
is he going to be the dual threat
quarterback that made him such an
incredible player three and four and
five years ago and that's going to be
the question remember mike
about 13 months ago in spartanburg south
carolina
i got cam newton for 20 minutes
and he talked about
changing his style of play as a
quarterback that he was going he saw
what quarterbacks did
late in their career to prolong their
career and even though he was only 30
years old you can't keep taking the
beating that cam newton took and expect
to be playing until you're 38 or 40
years old so he was on the way to
changing
now my question is
you know is josh mcdaniels going to give
him 80 to 100 rush attempts because he
knows that that's the way he's got to
play to move the chains
and a mobile versatile
quarterback can make up for a lot of
ills in a receiving corps
yeah and that's something that josh
mcdaniels hasn't had in new england with
tom brady i'll go back a decade when
josh mcdaniels drafted tim tebow he
specifically constructed an offense that
he never got to use in denver because he
got fired before he had a chance to use
it but the next year when tebow became
the starter they dusted it off they used
that offense and it's conducive to
keeping the quarterback healthy if the
blocking is there and that's going to be
the challenge dante scarnecki have
finally gone the offensive line guru for
the patriots but if they can keep cam
newton clean if they can keep him from
getting hit they keep him from getting
hurt and he can be that dual threat
peter that makes up for the deficiencies
in the passing game
and not only that mike but he needs one
of these two rookie tight ends to come
in and be a factor early because just
remember
what is the one thing that you could
always take to the bank with the new
england patriots at least until last
year they were going to throw the ball
to the tight end all day josh mcdaniels
loves the intermediate part of the field
and so to me
they need the tight end position to be
more productive than it was a year ago
and i'm really really anxious to see the
play calls
uh that josh mcdaniels makes with his
new toy
every team is a work in progress from
september until the end of december they
get better or they get worse they rarely
stay the same and with all the chaos
that is happening in the nfl with covet
19 and the uncertainty and the rules
changes and all the opportunities to
manipulate the rules i like for the
patriots to get better not worse as the
season goes on and if cam newton stays
healthy i think they're going to be a
factor when january rolls around check
us out all season long for more pft ot
videos on yahoo sports he's peter king
i'm mike florio we'll see you next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports